this program is designed to give you a
working knowledge of the design thinking
process that we teach at the d-school
it's meant to equip you with some
understanding of the way the design
thinking approach to innovation works my
particular area of design thinking is
how you use design thinking for
organizational change and particularly
around introducing new ways of working
in order to help your organization get
to new outcomes to continue to serve the
purpose that you're meant to serve as
the world changes you'll start with some
basics of design and we'll go through
all the different disciplines in design
and you'll learn
the tools and techniques
and will build your skills as a
practitioner we think that as important
as the theory and the application are
equally important to that is your
ability to take the tools that you're
learning and infuse them into what we
call a daily creative practice here's
what you need to know about your daily
practice
you need to carve out some time to do
this every day
maybe you're too focused on getting the
best idea or the right idea and we're
going to help you shift through this
practice to focus on quantity of ideas
but the course ultimately isn't only
about you catalyzing true breakthrough
work in an organization is about
enlisting the enthusiasm of others and
leading people through these tools you
know i may be a bit biased um but you
have the a team here and i'm sure you're
going to have a great experience of
learning and enjoying yourself through
this program
so
so long for me and good luck
[Music]